Please welcome Leslie Jordan.
(audience applauds)
(claps) Leslie.
And look at you two.
You look so good, both of you.
Oh, you look so good too.
You look, you look very proper
in a little scarf, ascotty thing.
Well, I dressed.
(audience laughs)
(Ross laughs)
I'm just so excited to be speaking with you here today.
I'm such a fan of yours,
and especially what you've done
and accomplished in 2020
with putting yourself out there on social media.
It's just been such a bright light for everyone.
Well, it wasn't really planned.
It just kinda happened.
I was stuck in Tennessee with my mom for the lockdown,
and I started doing Instagrams to pass the time.
I did two a day for 80 days, and I just,
without even thinking it through.
I didn't go anywhere near politics.
I didn't go anywhere near religion.
I just wanted to give people, you know,
a place to go where they could just laugh.
You know, people come up to me in grocery stores
and say, "Oh, Mr. Jordan, I was stuck at home.
I got three kids, my husband, la la la.
I would come to you once a day just for a good laugh,
and I would look forward to it."
You know, you realize how important
just comedy is, especially now,
during all of this.
I completely agree.
You are a national treasure,
and you have made people,
and that authenticity of putting it out there
with those brilliant intentions
is probably why it connected so much with everybody.
So, thank you.
Yeah, and 2020 was-
Well, you're welcome.
It was so hard, Leslie.
And every day, I know myself and millions of other people
would go to your IG, just to feel better.
So, thank you for what you gave us.
Thank you, honey.
That's so sweet.
Leslie, would you be kind enough
to join us in some headlines at the news desk?
Absolutely.
(audience claps)
Oh, good, okay Ross.
Take it away.
Okay, let's see, gotta talk.
So many people are conducting
radical hair experiments this year,
because people growin' it out in quarantine.
"Men's Health" says if you've ever mulled a mullet,
the time is now.
And celebs are showing off their (laughs) party tails
from Miley Cyrus to Billie Eilish,
and of course, country star Morgan Wallen rocks a mullet.
And stylists say it is now the prime time
for a mullet moment,
'cause people have been growing their hair out,
so you can trim the sides.
A mullet doesn't work for everybody.
I am pretty passionate that it, you know,
business in the front and,
poor life choices in the back.
Did we have a moment?
(Drew and Leslie laughing)
But this is what I would look like with a mullet, Drew.
I have to say, sorta hot.
Anyone else?
Ross, I'm in.
You're in?
Yeah.
Well, let's see what you would look like
in a mullet (laughs).
(Drew laughs)
Okay, Drew, I'm out (laughs).
And Leslie, we got you too.
Wow.
Oh, you look sweet.
Are you a mullet man, Leslie?
No, not at all.
No.
I remember the very first mullet I saw,
was probably Jane Fonda, believe it or not.
For "Klute."
Oh, yes.
She had that movie called "Klute."
But see, back then, we called it the shag, I think.
But it was a mullet.
(laughs) It was a mullet.
Yeah.
Everybody had the shag.
But no, I never had that.
I did, you know, I was,
in 1969 I was 14.
So all I wanted out of life was to be a hippie.
And I had all this hair,
and my hair was kinda red, big.
I looked like a little rock and roll troll doll.
(Drew and Ross laughing)
I'm this big with all that hair (laughs).
By the way, if you can get us a picture of that, Leslie,
we would be thrilled.
We would love to see that.
Oh, I don't, (indistinct) I burned 'em.
Oh, well, I bet you looked so good.
Okay, well, sticking with style news,
let's turn to the latest in furry fashion.
"InStyle" reports that you can now buy
UGG Boots for your dog.
Finally.
Yep, that's right.
Put a pug in an UGG.
(Ross laughs)
These booties come in a classic tan,
and in a black with green trim.
Leslie, do you have a little doggie?
Would you put them in UGGs?
I don't have a doggie,
and I don't get UGGs.
Don't your feet sweat?
(Ross laughs)
No.
There was Pam Anderson,
runnin' on the beach.
I thought, I bet her feet stink.
(Ross laughs)
I don't think I'm a UGGer.
Well, listen.
I'm not a UGGy guy.
I have three dogs, and they're,
you know, we live in Palm Springs.
And coming here to New York,
these dogs, their feet are cold.
So I want a rush order.
Oh, there you go.
Don't take pause (laughs).
I'm kidding.
Don't pause today.
Don't pause.
You know what's also really helpful
about these UGGs,
is that in East Coast places,
it's not something I knew growing up in California.
They salt the roads,
and that salt actually burns the dogs' paws.
It's really toxic for them.
It burns right through the skin.
So you'll see a dog,
so the UGG Boots are really smart for that,
and then Robin, she is really heavy into design,
and was like, "You know what?
I have lighter carpets, and I put my dogs in them
so they don't ruin them when we take them outside."
Mm, mm.
Well, there you go.
So, don't burn your dog,
and keep your carpets clean.
(Ross laughs)
Leslie, and you would look cute with a little dog,
I gotta say.
Oh, I've had dogs over the years.
I've always had big dogs.
I love Labs.
But then again,
I went through a long Jack Russell Terrier phase.
Mm-hm.
I had little Earl for 18 years.
Little Earl.
I had a little Jack Russell.
Oh.
He was a criminal, honey.
Had a rap sheet long as your arm.
(audience laughs)
(Ross laughs)
I couldn't, I never even paper trained him.
He wouldn't even (laughs) paper train.
His dog is a criminal (laughs).
I love it.
Well, you have stolen our hearts, Leslie Jordan,
for many years, and you really propped us up
in the year we needed it most.
Thank you for joining us.
Well, you both
are just precious,
and I wish you the best
(audience applauds)
with this show.
Well, thank you Leslie.
(upbeat contemporary music)